هنادي وجيهان قصه شغف ارتبطت بالرسم
فحاولتا بكل جهدا ان تصبح من المتميزات في
مجتمع ماربي محافظه اريد له ان يكون مغلقه
بدون فرشاه او معجون الالوان التي تستخدم
في هذا الرسم بل بالابره والخيطه تمكنتها
من صناعه لوحات فنيه غير تقليديه
اختلفنا من جهه اللون وبعد التفكير واتفاق
اتمنى اللون الاسود والابيض لتعاكس
الالوان
رسمناها في تقريبا في 9 ساعات لدكتور عبد
العزيز المقالح عرضناها شفناها اقبال كبير
من الجمهور اعجب بها طلبوا منها رسمات
مختلفه من مديريه حريب جنوبيه مارب حضر
الكثير من المبدعين في مجالات شتى وحضرت
هنادي وجهان بفن تشكيلي جديد ولان معرضه
معرفه الثاني للكتاب كان نافذه ثقافيه
وابداعيه على العالم فقد كان ايضا
بوابتهما للشهره من خلال اللوحات
والرسومات التي لاقت رواجن كبيره حيث بدات
بشخصيه المعرض واديب اليمن الراحل عبد
العزيز
المقالحه
وحسينا احنا كمان بفاخر وكان في اقبال
كثير من الناس علينا والحمد لله
طب اجي انا اول تجربه شخصيه مشهوره والحمد
لله ضبطت معنا
وبعدين جربنا الثاني تجربه بعدين قلنا
بدنا نفتح انا وهي محل الكتروني المتجر
الالكتروني يعني مفتوح وان شاء الله نحصل
اجبار من الاشخاص
ماربوا ارضوا الحضاره والتاريخ بموروثها
ومخزنها الانسانيه والاثري الشامل هي
المشروع القادمه لفتياتها المبدعات في
متجر الكتروني كان فكره وصار بعد هذا
الاقبال جاهزا لطلب اللوحات الفنيه محمود
الحميدي العربيه مارب